alex even with covet 19 restrictions  plenty of people are traveling for the  holidays you might be as well  the tsa reports more than a million  people were screened at airports on  friday and saturday  in fact saturday marked the first time  u.s airports screened more than a  million passengers for two straight days  since the pandemic started however  passenger volumes are still  well down compared to normal 60 percent  lower than last year this time  more travelers are expected to pass  through airports as we get closer to  christmas however  and if you're flying out of mccarran  because i don't think there's any other  where else you can fly out of right now  for christmas  plan a little extra time the airport has  lowered shuttle capacities to allow for  more social distancing  so that means some of the wait times  might be a bit longer  masks are required on all shuttles at  mccarran alex